check check check we're and welcome to
punch-drunk sports where winners win yes
old-school vintage [ __ ] where can you
get those shirts you're they're gonna be
available on punch-drunk sports comm
which is coming out literally in two
weeks hi guys welcome to a arm a
different punch-drunk
I got so I'm so mad with power I fired
everybody on the show everyone's gone
Tebow's gone [ __ ] Johnny's gone fight
nanny's gone Ari's gone I is just me and
my new cool friend your punch drunk with
power
yeah well I'm punch drunk with power
joining us as our join us of course is
Chad sumac who's a part of the show now
and then the one and only the man of
mystery and magic The Dark Knight Jimmy
Huber Jimmy thanks for coming on show
dude thanks for having me and man you
know I feel I feel bad lot of big shoes
here to film yeah well you know what
shows got to grow sometimes yeah I try
to do my best brother you guys just
growing pains so yeah it's like the dead
weight sometime and bringing some new
people out I'm like a sandbag off our
hot air balloon it's losing altitude 100
in the poops you had that dart buck
that's right stretch you had that
leather cheerier like an old raincoat
Jimmy shoe or a player Triple E since I
live in LA now chi do a little kiss
assing yeah a little okay Jimmy
Schubert's one of the best comedians
working today and I'm now saying he's
like a [ __ ] monster on stage he is
one of the back and he's one of the few
guys you go in the room to watch yeah
for sure that's awful nice shoes yeah
thank you for the kind but if I lived in
Cleveland I can't say I'm in LA now I
gotta say that stuff yeah okay you can't
be nice and Cleveland's how you're
saying I love it through those chicks
got fat asses and they will have your
baby that's why I said about oh hi old
girls bro something about Ohio girl I
ain't afraid they're down predict I'd
like to get on a business end of a flesh
bone yeah there we go
like a guy who's wearing boxer shorts
and knows how to use them like a guy
who's not afraid to if I can flip it
over and throw a couple tongue darts
and straighten it out bro so trade it
out Jimmy ah you are part of this new
movement by white men who have been
ignored by Hollywood to put out their
own specials you produce it and at some
point you just say why am I asking
people to put it out I'm gonna put out
my [ __ ] Sal yeah well quite
essentially that's what happened I mean
you know when you're doing comedy
professionally it's like you know I
don't you know this world we live in now
with social media and the power of the
podcast and the fact that you know the
comedy store and comedy itself is
booming I mean you can literally I mean
I was thinking about the other day you
know I talked to about like in the
course of a weekend we're in economy we
talked about a thousand to fifteen
hundred people week to come in there
that like what you do and then you steer
them go go get my special not to mention
do podcast like this they're usually
successful and you tell people to go do
it and people do and and so you really
don't need you know you get my special
you can rent my special for 399 less
than a cup of [ __ ] coffee you can
rent my house realize and take a loan
out for that take a second there's a
shark at this pool [ __ ] alcohol give me
money from where do you get your special
at how do you like yeah we're you can go
to Johnny look it up oh yeah Jack it's
on it's on Vimeo but they can go to
Jimmy Stewart dot-com
go to Jimmy Shubert dot-com go to Jimmy
Schubert com.com
and that's Schubert SH you beat your
ticket it's right there on the front
page they'll take you right to the Vimeo
there's a rent there's a buy option it's
look I rented I rented mission
impossible 3 for 399 and quite frankly I
will tell you that my special is much
funnier than mission upon it's better
than mission impossible 3 it's funnier
than impossible that's for sure dude and
I'm set well look who's back
I guess I didn't fire you please welcome
to the show you can't see him Johnny
Woodard from North Carolina
Johnny waters in the head what Johnny
Nan's gonna be here so another person I
guess I decided I won't fire so now I
just fired Tebow's at it why don't you
guys late like it's very unprofessional
hey dude you you don't decide what's
professional here but it's our time
professional to us it's 10 minutes late
being on time is
but yeah I know people are watching the
livestream they're like watching it wait
well the beauty of it is is that as the
show goes new people keep coming in
yeah so it's yeah actually a bad thing
goddamnit layers it's like the janitor
Apple telling us why we [ __ ] [ __ ] with
our phones all the time just clean the
[ __ ] and shut up what's going on bro
seriously
I said you're taking this IQ with a
[ __ ] tire gauge tell us what we need
to do you know what
Schubert's like a better version of you
[Laughter]
look going in it's like it's like you
know it's like a party I have no real
power here hey can you block Johnny when
you're done like fixing your tampon or
whatever you do over there can you huh
can you go to Jimmy's Oh calm so we
could see his pull up that [ __ ] pull up
that stuff probably look at that oh you
got a chat our block code everybody yeah
did they want my tax money they know I'm
paying so it's schubert not with a see
that what I see it says st. you think of
how I rank who's that looks like my
website this I can't be reached
that's not you guys never go in the dark
that professional oh let's go holy [ __ ]
three lash two one zero tolerance a
sterile face so it sets right there and
that's you can go literally click on
that button buy or rent did you just
touch the TV yeah cuz I'm trying to like
people are watching I want to and then
it just takes you right to the render by
but makes it real easy
oh that's like your zero Fox yeah zero
Fox zero tolerance the zero foxes your
tolerance
we've just had up to here yeah but
[ __ ] idiot yeah I said [ __ ] god
I'm tired if I could play baby games
I'm tired of spoon feeding these [ __ ]
douche bags I'm over it dude I'm over it
so zero [ __ ] I mean some [ __ ]
therapy animals airplanes I mean we've
just gotten dumber and dumber
people like what [ __ ] branch with
restroom you gotta use I'm gonna call
I'm gonna call my attorney
hey guys
number two I mean forget the boy huh I
can get 5 to 10 for taking the number 2
in Des Moines I but I hold it till
Cleveland it's too late you know the
problem is this is just like there's so
much there's so much chaos out there
like are you guys on Verizon do you guys
have really you know did you guys notice
did Chad did you notice that suddenly
you started getting all these spam calls
yeah right just and then I like three
days later Verizon Wireless comes out
with this hey we got this new app that
blocks spam calls yeah I get spam calls
I'm t-mobile and I they're not blocked
you like three a day I'm at a point
where I actually welcome to spam goal
only I like spam calls I'm looking for
hot young ladies who are looking for sex
locally I yes
yeah I mean has anyone ever buy anything
from a spam email call or anything and
they got the worst timing you could be
kneeling over your mother's lifeless
body goes hey congratulations you just
one dance lessons for the whole family
yeah well mom won't be making it you
know it'll just be you know I mean they
get to you know okay I call me which the
[ __ ] smell use an outdated
terminology yeah can I speak with the
master of the house of God who you think
lives here Thomas Jefferson chill out
you're killed don't call me master hang
in there kill all my killing all my
action with the black chick [ __ ]
[ __ ] joke that's alright won't happen
again
look at all these spam call Sam Tripoli
Sam Tripoli Sam Tripoli Sam Tripoli I
got a Verizon come on bro I actually
have you listened to my phone it's good
it comes up spam calls yeah the trips
side you're awesome special what else
where are you gonna be any shows coming
up yeah yeah yeah call the pulpit or
days I have to go to Phoenix we're gonna
Rick Bronson sounds of comedy most
people love those brick and Tammy Tammy
I have to roast the an NHL player doing
it for charity yeah I'm gonna film it
Bonnie McFarland's filming it but Nicole
yeah Earl Skakel's on it and Joe bartnik
and all these like they're great so it's
gonna move to the who's oli this weekend
and can we power rank
arts comedians in terms of how cool they
are like comics you know that our hockey
fans conks you know and that our
basketball fans football fans designers
the number one like a sports fan I heart
who's the coolest - the biggest [ __ ]
right now Joe bartnik hockey
I think the hockey are the nicest I
don't never know anything as well as Joe
Bartnik knows [ __ ] high Sevan I mean
there's a wonderful a nice dude every
time you see Joe bartnik he's just
[ __ ] killing harder like a man dude
show with me um when I went for the ATC
festival I was playing Bronson's room he
came into a guest spot and dude dude
dude slam like slam yeah I got to do a
roast with him so I'm a little nervous
because I know he's a broke roast joke
writer him and Skakel are gonna come for
me at me cuz I mean you know there's no
there's really nobody else when the
panel does yeah god is on there if I'm
not mistaken whoever I think so I think
it's all it on the website sir Theon no
she's not okay she's not judge Sarah I
got this is hockey dude we don't need
[ __ ] Oh Danny would you like a way
he's got to be Tebow once he was gonna
do multiple jobs here no it's true it's
true I mean like you know I I'm sorry I
I can't watch the girls on the site look
you want girls on the sidelines what the
cheerleaders are for I don't need to
have a woman like they come up why they
do that they come up to halftime and
they're always like this so coach what
you think yeah well they did hook them
there so they could ask anything and if
there's a [ __ ] push back everyone
Christ sexism like when you saw when
Nick's save ended with that smokin hot
black chick that's on ESPN
like she's hot as [ __ ] you know and
she's like so what do you think about
the controversy between your quarterback
and he just blew up on her but everybody
knows he blows up on everybody that's
par for the course if you're gonna
interview Nick Saban Sam can you keep
doing that do why you're sucking go
stick yeah you can sort of look like I'm
just saying
Chad you mods go stick some boys go
stick soccer bro okay so what I was
gonna be
I mean why no you're always working
where's the door tape around here yeah
relax yeah I got a couple things I had
to that this thing come out but uh yeah
doing spots around town and I got I just
did a movie that's coming up yeah I'm
gonna be in Harvey's in Portland we got
the fantasy Springs Resort right parents
Brad Garrett always working always
what's that you're always working well
yeah well yeah I mean we're sharks dude
if we stop swimming we die dude I love
[ __ ] I got em Oh more towards this
Harry basil letting you do Brad Garrett
I'm surprising that freaking out Oh
controversy let me tell you something I
took the month of January off just so I
could do podcast to promote my specials
so that's why there's no tour dates
coming you know buddy you know if you
said like he's always moving anyway
there's the tour okay Chad where you
gonna be unfortunately that's [ __ ] up
man yeah we should we he's gonna be in a
fetal position it's closeted me working
on that callus on the roof of his mouth
from a loaded revolver that's what he's
gonna be doing til the end of February
chad is you know I'm like you always
like do like when your kid grow she
always like that dude on the wall Chad
does that on shotguns how farther down
he can deep throat the shotgun he loves
a little thing so hopefully someday I'll
have it all the way down that's that
shad neck where you gonna be
do you go to therapy after this because
you just need this is my therapy Alice
on your feelings yeah I mean people
coming in as the show start
yeah I was professional I got here on
game yeah the guests usually beat us
it's very fine
finally that propagandas done what's up
I'm at the Ontario improv this weekend
with african-american Godfrey not
Gilbert Godfrey okay Godfrey's great
he's the best I think like Godfrey's the
one name and comedian you got to be
really funny you got to go hard if your
name's Godfrey and they're all the I
know two and they're both well that's
his real is he can't pronounce his first
name nobody can't pronounce it yes it's
sound it's like Sebastian nobody could
say a Maniscalco for the longer
time so he just dropped his first name
and just uses his last name yeah so what
is this first what is alright I'll pull
it up so you're working with the guy you
don't even know dude I've known him for
10 years I don't know how to pray he
just goes by Godfrey and everybody
doesn't Gilbert from one of those
Hollywood power blacks watching guys one
name there it is Godfrey Dutch maja
junior junior I don't know can you
pronounce that first of all it's his
dance not Dutch dance shimmy for [ __ ]
how to pronounce me I know
gone that could be its own segment yeah
but yours the classic Benjamin Godfrey
densha junior that's not that bad well
we know something you know I just got a
lot of people just go by one name yeah
yeah you know I'd like to go by my full
name it's JFS or my initials but it's
Jimmy [ __ ] Schubert I like that you
do that can i name my kid [ __ ] in the
middle there's a middle name yeah would
it be great can yell yeah Kenya yeah
that's in Africa I guarantee you there's
gonna be a mom in this new generation
that's gonna put a @ symbol in front of
their kids name on a birth certificate I
wouldn't be funny ampersand the kid's
name so like his actual twitter handle
is his real name yeah yeah just make
sure it's not taken before you dude I
have to go on although my love from
Messiah to Hitler what you can oh there
you go name your kid Hitler no you can't
you can't you cannot well did I just
watch a documentary on Hitler you know
let's hear about you know we had a
[ __ ] Audi boats here we can talk all
the tinfoil hat we want no no no he dude
he had a [ __ ] girlfriend like [ __ ]
dude but he was [ __ ] shooting math
bro bro when you saw him like Venus not
a sleaze lucky balls right there dude
[ __ ] Eva Braun she was a [ __ ]
smoke show and she proven once again
chicks always go for the [ __ ] dude
but he was I loved about it Darth Vader
came down 17 when they met he was 40 and
they really
didn't tell anybody because quite
frankly I got the guy that murdered half
of Europe they won't be known as worries
a creeper word is he killed the Jews
just so nobody talked about him banging
underage chicks yes look at that ass the
reason she wasn't allowed to tell
anybody that she was dating Adolf Hitler
because he thought part of his charm was
like he was attractive like the women
Doug yet ain't off like he may not be
much to you now but 1934 lady was like
hell and he was like fact literally like
Matthew McConaughey or Berlin oh yeah he
was like the Matthew McConaughey
remember he's like 30 1934 Berlin that's
why she wouldn't tell anybody and now
I'm about to make Hitler seem like more
of an [ __ ] before they took the
cyanide he gave it to his dog so he
killed the dog first killed the dog
first and he was a good son died he was
inconsolable have died in Argentina dog
he didn't die they finally liked his leg
yeah that's all I didn't die can't even
work on a bit with [ __ ] tinfoil hat
hair that's so funny I must stop jumping
your lines okay gotta breathe I was I
just was noticing it last Johnny in the
penalty box right now independent it's
so funny guys I'm going to be where my I
only know where the [ __ ] I'm gonna be
man well we're judging you now you have
comedy chaos tonight yeah it's sold out
so that so you don't even need to
promote it buddy now no no it's already
sold out if I'm all the time yeah dude
then they you know nice I was nice and
I've asked me to listen art he's doing
two main room shows so can you please
give this other guy that losses the
second show and I'm like good cool then
I find out who it was and it's not who I
everybody thought it was with somebody
else
and he basically did my lamp and sold
out so I like I helped this piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ] sellout make money putting
me on the Flyers yeah yeah I don't know
what that's like bro I've never
I've been invited to do a chaos shows oh
that's [ __ ] up you know the best
comics out there simply douchebags he's
got a special on already yeah here we go
all right take care of it fortunately
drunk sports where winners win are you
in town February 26 yes but I would go
your honor to date my phone every 26 Ron
go but I'm cool but I'm Chad you are a
cool man Thank You Chad get in the
penalty box go getting a bit put them in
the bedroom put them innovation so yeah
I'm doing now I'm doing shows in our
Long Beach now I'm gonna start doing
harvelle's again oh I love that place
I love it dude that's a great place
shoot especially I don't know why he'll
what he's done it yet well did I did
mine I did mine in flappers but I
actually I do going know I looked right
but great bathroom should beep I don't
know why it's not packed all the time
that dude I just love the audience's era
I mean they're like working-class like a
road audience y'all a so when you get
out of like Hollywood comedy is fun in
the LA area yeah I noticed it like at
the improv when you're like doing shows
the improv there's people sitting you
know I'm in show business too you know
yeah yeah he's like I don't know what
happens over there really like it really
seems like it's more but I mean at the
Comedy Store great audience as well as
does it cool tourists what I mean
some nights at The Comedy Store I mean
like you're like they got to be getting
tired and you go up and there's still
[ __ ] fire yeah you're like god damn
you know I like some of these are like
you know like star-fuckers I got who are
you what did you Jack yeah you know like
they want you know they're won't you be
they want you to be more famous than
funny yeah I don't know where it goes
the other way I'm funnier than I love
when they come they think there's rules
the comedy - that's fun like you can't
say that I just did the plates catch on
fire is the world coming to an end
did I say something that you didn't
think was right and nobody died denied
to follow you would not the original you
were talking about the [ __ ] salt
around the rim in the ass crack like a
margarita glass and is my old Coke -
there's old visual imagery of the [ __ ]
said yes just amazing
I mean I get everything but you know
it's so funny when you're playing like
all these great crops like I've been
blessed we go on the road with this my
other podcast and does we're doing
really well and I'm starting to play my
crowd which is weird yeah I'm playing a
crowd I used to be just like a hired guy
it would just be me great but the great
thing is is that they know you're
working they're there to see you
specifically about what you do so you
don't have to worry about yeah all the
[ __ ] cuz they know what they're
getting yeah you know hire Sam triply
you get Sam trip like you don't gonna
sugarcoat it anymore you don't have to
tiptoe through the tulips with your
[ __ ] references in your so the
Bronson's were really nice and they
booked me to play out the polar vortex
two weeks in a row those are the
blessings of being a comic and I flew in
during like historically bad I mean like
you watch the weather like minus 40 here
minus 35 year I'm like this is not real
life is it but people still came out and
it was just crazy they'll dude yeah
crazy
dude that's the thing about you know
traveling like that in February I mean I
got a show got canceled last year I was
doing a parks in Philly
this casino and I'm still with my
special there's zero jokes you get one
get out of jail free cards okay March
21st snowstorm cancels the show March
21st who would think March 21st would be
a snowstorm cuz I live in LA I'm not
used to it if there's a snow in my front
yard
he usually fell in my pocket yeah
see how I let that go I didn't say
anything yeah you didn't trample over a
bunch like really bad today so yeah so
go to my website Sam dubli.com what is
going on well what is Apple over the
place epileptic I remember my dad is do
you know I was working at this
restaurant and this guy comes in and I'm
sit with the manager was a buddy of mine
at the time we were like kids younger
kids he goes you know I have epilepsy
right and the guy goes no because you
know what to do if I have an attack yeah
guys give you a couple brillo pads and
pull you towards the dirty wall called
comedy guys comedy gods hey Chad
hilarious whatever bro is this some kind
of Owen Benjamin some [ __ ] hack
that's going on bro oh here comes the
Bears dude oh man not acceptable error
404 yeah that should be the name of your
next match oh there's your dumb website
it's working there you go damn - Chad
wait I need a new website by the way
let's talk after you but how great is
that
yeah that's html5 look how great that is
dude you got a lot going on right there
bro yeah I have like tons of dates I put
none of them in my calendar I'm just so
busy I just haven't had time to sit down
and just tediously put enough I just had
an email to my guy and he does I got a
great guy I wish I had that person you
have so many people working everything I
got do everything yeah what am I paying
you for
you know a lot of these people they're
like blisters they show up after the
works done yeah but sick of it quite
frankly I'm sick of it I also follow the
punch-drunk Instagram yeah
because already posting pictures of
himself all over our Instagram I just
put one what is funny Humana do what
happens if Instagram goes down bro what
are all these Instagram models gonna do
Brian
they're gonna have to go back to the
pole Instagram modeling Instagram is
literally created twerking as a almost a
sport at this point I wouldn't doubt if
at some point the Olympics which what
are you doing where's fun are you in the
blood Chad blown Bethan I knew on the
right the big guy he said to me yeah I
borrowed it from an ex-girlfriend can't
Roosevelt Rough Riders shout out what
are you going in field hockey girl randy
rhoads there's gonna lesbian dude if i
did comedy in that outfit now I would
get a Netflix bus yeah you told he would
just talking about how hard it is to be
used I'm gonna do an hour special about
quitting stand-up comedy it's unbeliev
been done
hey listen you want to quit stand-up
comedy quit stand-up calm yeah get the
[ __ ] out
don't make a [ __ ] look it's a tough
[ __ ] business okay comedy is really
tough if you're really tough if you're
anybody in [ __ ] comedy I don't care
it's just a [ __ ] tough way to make a
living I would love to have Hannah
Gatsby who like follow [ __ ] Tripoli in
the o.r that'd be the best she would be
able to fill in a gallery fans yeah
she's just known as the mediocre Gatsby
yeah is the Great Gatsby and that's the
mediocre gatsby you don't have any
problem with her special I haven't
honestly watch it blah blah blah I'd
rather go to the dentist to get my gum
scrape me face down in the chair and go
in the long way to get to defend
someone's right to do shitty comedy but
my problem is afterwards when she gets
on a soapbox and starts yelling and
screaming - [ __ ] everybody about you
know we're you know this met what man
good man but man need to do marks like
shut the [ __ ] up shut up if you hate me
so much why are you trying to look like
one
yeah you'll see people were afraid of
cloud dressing up like [ __ ] and
really how tough could it be to be a
woman
when freakin what's-his-name Jenner
turned to do a woman transition woman
and becomes Woman of the Year his first
try out of the gear and he was Woman of
the Year men are killing it as women
yeah they're killing it let me have you
watch high school sports these dudes are
putting a wig on dominated on a row and
now all the other women are second oh
yeah well guess what you want it this is
sweet
yeah [ __ ] cry-baby yes yeah my
daughter's not gonna scholarship cuz
there's a couple of [ __ ] dudes with
dicks running in the [ __ ] world women
are running around this is mean and
white guys are you know will come when
you want some [ __ ] drop hammer again
and restore everything just like you
know it's like who's like man I watch
this female I did a rose I did a uh open
mic for a friend of mine who who passed
away uh this the the dojo and this one
female comic came up and she's doing
like I'm training to a guy I'm just like
lazy and I don't do [ __ ] I'm like how
many women died in World War two five
yeah 5 five yeah 5 I said right French
chicks they were blown the [ __ ] Nazi
when the bombs [ __ ] drop yeah that's
a funny bit you know it's like what are
you talking about what are we talking
well you know what you know you're first
off when someone says that and you like
to throw around those phrases first time
you let me know you're [ __ ] it cuz
you haven't read any of your [ __ ]
history books [ __ ] old white guys
why'd you do some what'd you find out
about the Khmer Rouge once you see what
the New Mexican guys when they cut off
heads and hang 25 body 25 headless
bodies off the [ __ ] bridges is that
all white guys doing that or you know
it's such a [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
thing you want to hurt you signal like
you're better than like hey you
completely discount the decades of men
whose sacrifice dude how about from the
first time yeah [ __ ] monkeys dude
yeah so what you're trying to say is we
need to murder more women know what I'm
saying is here
all that stuff is fine but you also have
to give them credit for the decades
where they sacrifice their centuries
millenniums millenniums of [ __ ]
providing shelter and food for women and
[ __ ] children so you can't just go
paint with these broad brushstrokes
because when you do that it comes back
to the other direction
right I mean it's like it's now or if
you did it about any other races it's
[ __ ] it's real-time it's [ __ ] you
know yeah hey dude there's some real
[ __ ] to that it's really sad that the
truth is [ __ ] dangerous now I don't
know everybody nobody wants to do any of
the critical thinking they want to watch
a guy like you know I used to be Jon
Stewart now it's Trevor Noah get up on
the soapbox and then they just walk
around recite when he says like that
like there are [ __ ] parts all
paradigm but Holly want a cracker
yeah they don't the nobody wants to do
their own investigation of the wrong
yeah and when you have the Internet you
can track down all this information and
find out what's real it's like they're
the dossier that this whole Russian
collusion thing is based on it's
basically based on an article that was
written in 2007 in the Wall Street
Journal now dude it's even deeper than
that it's like you look up Stephen arm
you go deep I'll send y'all [ __ ] i dude
right now I already see the tweets Jason
we missed you this [ __ ] podcast
became tinfoil hat without you okay so
let's talk sport yeah what's Jimmy
Stewart Sports what do you like love
football bro football hockey baseball so
this article comes out and by the way
anybody watch Colin Cowherd like I
normally like him he has just gone fully
[ __ ] like he can't stop praising
LeBron James [ __ ] on what Russell
Westbrook but he brought this great
story that Brian Hoyer who used to
always be a quarterback to the Browns
lawyer he was with the ramps right yeah
who's the back of handouts and the
Titans so now he is the backup
quarterback for the Patriots so he
started watching all this [ __ ] about the
you know because the Rams did like that
Amazon Prime show and all this is ESPN
plus stuff and he started watching it
was I wonder if they're running the
offense that is it Kyle Shanahan is that
his name runs in San Francisco and he
started watching it and he realized it
was the
back same playbook yeah so he knew
everything they were running he knew
when they do this check down that check
down what this means understanding that
the Patriots defensive coordinator no
I'm telling you that the [ __ ] backup
quarterback for the [ __ ] Patriots for
two weeks
played [ __ ] are the what's his name
who's Jeffrey gonna play golf
in the practices he had been studying
the Rams all the footage he could find
he just sent from an internet watch
everything about Rams practices and he
realized they were running the offense a
he'd ran when he was in San Francisco
and he knew exactly everything that they
were gonna do now is that wrong no it's
not relevant aeneas no I'm well you know
the thing is I like last year when the
Eagles won the Super Bowl you added two
couple Patriots were there that knew
that knew the kind of playbook I mean it
just happens but you're right it's
interesting that the guys went to that
extreme I mean how many [ __ ] plays
can you run an offense I mean you know
what this is you know it's like I think
this system they weren't in Philly
operates better with Nick Foles and it
does yeah with you know Carson Wentz
Carson Wentz is a great quarterback but
I think that system runs better with
Nick Foles but you know he's getting
ready to go he bought it out of his
option what do you think he's gonna wind
up oh dude Jacksonville might be good
Jacksonville is interesting there's so
many calm so many quarterbacks in play
for that if they went all-in and got
like a next-level guy like somehow I
don't know if we can match but something
like a Matthew Stafford
oh no yeah destroy a big balls is gonna
get [ __ ] paid so wherever he goes
they're gonna be bought out of his
contract for two million so it's time
for him to get his little [ __ ] you
know 154 million or whatever they're
gonna pay for his nick foles gonna be is
he gonna excel in another system and
another coach well obviously well would
you have to realize is you know and
that's why the the genius of the
Petersons was that he saw what nick
falls dead in college Pilon runs in
college nick falls broke wall drew brees
passing records in college now drew
Brees was a Purdue and and Nick was at
ASU but I mean that guy's a however
throw over football even when you watch
him like I mean the guy I mean just
throws the only where his receivers good
the guy's a great quarterback he's got
that you know so
see what happened you know the guy who
was his quarterback coach for a while
and Billy is now I believe the head
coach of Jacksonville ah there you go so
that was a great that you know just put
the system around him I mean he's only
34 he's still got a couple of years in
the league I think I think he did he won
the Super Bowl I actually thought that
if they if he came that why this would
be great for sports if a guy like Nick
Falls came in as a backup second you're
going like you know like towards the end
of the season and took the team back to
the Super Ball I thought that would have
been a great story I thought that would
have been amazing obviously there's a
discussion is he a Hall of Famer I'm
here like I'm not sure absolutely I
agree but you have to look at I mean
that's coming from a guy who was getting
ready to like quit two years ago you
know I mean he played for Jeff Fischer
Jeff Fischer is in the quarterbacks
coach I mean he's running he's my
brother of offense Jeff Jeff Fischer is
[ __ ] from right out of [ __ ] Madden
brow rookie mode bro what a place
you know he says the defensive guy but
they were it wasn't much
he was like over you can't touch the
it's the Oprah D for them you get a
touchdown
you get his heart out you get to touch
them Chad you were supposed to join that
Simone I'm meeting crackers you guys are
flowing I I'm a professional broadcaster
what do you think lavon's not what do
you think runs back my Bell's gonna go
burn I don't know man it's interesting
like I mean he's a great running back we
saw like you know at first Pittsburgh
was doing really well without him and
then it kind of fell off I think where
you go I'm like I would love to see him
on the Colts a lot of people are talking
about the the Raiders getting him I mean
do you want pay that I mean if we're
gonna keep car then we keep him if we're
not keeping car why spend that much
money on a [ __ ] running back yeah I
mean we're gonna be playing I think in a
[ __ ] the girls field hockey field
next year and I was just up there that
that stadiums is looking pretty good
they're getting there like I mean he's
right yeah it's like right by the
highway yeah it's like right downtown
ready for another season we got to play
somewhere next year yeah it's just
the NFL's just so their hatred of the
Raiders is stronger than theirs their
hatred for everything I mean I can't
stand a company like NFL who doesn't
understand what your brand is but people
are tuning in
I don't want your politics on my
football field I don't want your [ __ ] I
wanna watch you guys play [ __ ]
football okay
I'm gonna spend $200 $300 to come out
and watch a game that's not even cool in
parking or hot dogs or whatever there I
mean I just want to watch football I'm
into people taking nice that's my thing
I like I want taking these because
that's the best way to suck dick what
sponsored by kneepads de Partie barbecue
man that she had side bet the side for
all your pet needs go to bed DSi use the
promo code punch punch
a hunch 25 and Candice is so chatty I
did she's perfect go to use it goes use
punch 25 and you'll get 20 you'll get
$25 betting cash and they will double
your whatever you deposit they'll match
it up to $500 wow that's great dude
they're great dude they've been with us
forever and I'm telling you man there's
nothing as hole there's nothing better
than talk to me but no no no [ __ ] too
sorry there's nothing better than a
gambling sponsorship because they just
they come with straight cash and they
call you from a different [ __ ]
third-world country every day in Costa
Rica yeah Costa Rica Panama Yugoslavia I
don't know where the [ __ ] she's like
Carmen Santiago I'm like where in the
world are you could we gamble we're
Antonio Browns gonna go yeah what we're
gonna start doing what are you thinking
to go ahh what's your thoughts I'd like
to see a man I would like to see him on
a colt
why is your Colts friend I just love
Andrew Luck yeah he's a good he's a good
he's a tough quarterback you know dude
like you almost couldn't play and he
came back and just murdered everybody
and it was so fun to watch like as
people are like they forgot how great
Andrew Luck was yeah like they got rid
of Peyton Manning for this guy yeah and
it's like I like it doesn't he does not
like cocky he's funny they say when you
hit him really hard he gets up goes to
that one
great hit bro I'm like crazy yeah it's
that mentality I'm he'll be yeah he'll
be looking for his keys when he's 55
rich killing white chicks yeah what what
he said he's looking for his keys when
he's 55 and killing white you get it
what's good what's good we're good is
having all that money if you're just
sitting there [ __ ] just hollering hey
do cuz you could be happy now that money
and still be slobbery you know I'm
saying you better that's very you can
change what Emily's truck do with goth
what to do a golf just tell me not to
give any [ __ ] signals I mean that's a
dude golf there's people like Clayton
Kershaw they caught his signals dude
that giant [ __ ] Asian and lost the
World Series for the Dodgers he was
tipping his pitches dude dude there's
whole people watching every second of
your [ __ ] of your [ __ ] game no for
anything that tips off well dude that's
like looks like what anything like like
with the UFC when you get a go get used
to go it goes undefeated for like five
matches then everybody see how these
fights and then get your number and then
someone comes out and beat you after you
know you set up your sitting never the
same after that yeah they're never the
same after that look at what's his name
whoo oh yeah what she she's in the WWE
right yeah she's just collecting checks
Wow that's all checks
well she's putting a check in a little
egg lock yeah for Jonah leglock bro who
is your right place right time more JJ
Redick on the Philadelphia 76ers or
Ronda Rousey being like the first of the
big and WWE nobody like she came in the
time when the women in the UFC were all
Tae Bo people like JJ into this JJ is
like people are like oh he's the
greatest
dude this lineup as it may be the
greatest night ever JJ Redick is Jay's
gar Bosh
dude he's having a great year I have a
great year and they're learning ok year
and he's round like dude it's like yeah
it's like dude it's imagine doing a show
where it's like Chad Zuma Richard Pryor
okay Sam K where where where's the hole
and they're like the five greatest
comics
the greatest throw him into the lineup
Chad's like yep [ __ ] great bro he's
the best ballet dancer on the [ __ ]
show yeah
des Moines Ballet Company huh well [ __ ]
it's that hard to do boy
yeah well they have our white guy out
there and he just fits the bill and
nobody's father he's a system like you
would that certain players together that
work and it works you're just mad
because he's not with the Clippers any I
think he's because he blows all those
guys after the show that's all I'm sorry
because it'll suck all their dicks those
guys are taking three pointers of
shooting at table juice yeah with three
Porter's Deniz good wise hair is perfect
it's got purple that [ __ ] Something
About Mary pomade going on use that the
next tinfoil hat talk about a jarful I
think he's [ __ ] fine I think what the
Anfal learned is that uh you can't be
Hollywood and just put pretty young
people in you know I like sports as
results you either get the results or
you don't Hollywood we don't know the
results we know what you tell well you
know a sports professional sports is
where a meritocracy the guy who's best
for the job gets the job period the end
you're not gonna have a you know you
know there's lesbians got a G I got a
quarterback rating at 1:26 you've called
no it's not like that it's just you
better be balanced rewarded talents
rewarded yeah in sports and that's
probably a little last a little you know
they're trying their hardest though
they're trying their hardest to ruin it
to just make it as Hollywood as possible
yeah I mean the last Super Bowl so bad
ratings I wait for this next generation
where these kids all grew up playing
sports but I got participation trophies
and there's a push back and they and
they have participation trophy wives
like I'm worried having a kid like I'm
like no there's a winner and a loser
yeah don't tell it now we don't take
those trophies we get those when we win
yeah and we learn from there are no
teams at all that do that cuz I would
like scout that out and be like no we're
gonna go play a real sport
everything if your Ford is super parents
you have no chance and well there's a
stupid parent right behind was a stupid
kid in fact parent my bank comes a
douchebag kid yeah it's like you know
you making a little human being try to
teach him some life like yes like every
kid I watch has trophies in the room
they're all these are not I'm like oh
what's this and they're like oh well we
play soccer every Saturday and everyone
wins we get the trophy out here I throw
that the minivan the broader years ago
you know we'll listen I got a trophy you
could yep it everybody got one yeah it
doesn't get one means nothing yeah Jimmy
Schubert has zero tolerance for this guy
see I plugged this special thank you for
professional 30 once again Jimmy sure
it's available to rent or buy you should
check out my [ __ ] Vimeo I have two
specials available well hi OFAC's bucks
and art Oh daddy I'm again and I'm gonna
get on zero [ __ ] Row is just where
we're going now how long your specials
ah
one is 42 minutes and the other one is
uh 35 okay mine's an hour so I just put
it all in the one special no it's fine
you have to I broke it up because I just
feel like nobody has any attention span
oh yeah you've got 12 more minutes
no no that's coming from analytics with
Netflix going well people only watch
comedy special for 15 minutes I know
it's common for 15 mins because most of
them [ __ ] blow yeah there's something
I do get that but I do know people's
attention spans oh god yeah I mean what
the [ __ ] and I don't want your [ __ ]
goddamn they're all the way that we're
better me or Hannah Gatsby beat us to
the punch look looks great dude dude is
so good that when I film zero jokes I'm
doing the o.r on a Monday when they do
the three minute spots yeah it's gonna
be three minutes long six three-minute
spots you know just so good I'm gonna
burn too much material are really six
specials nobodies I'm the Cleveland
centric guy here there was some Hannah
boy gave you that title but really she
everyone's saying I'm the king like I'm
bringing over the Cleveland buddy
you're the what uh there's been a lot a
lot of backlash to us signing running
back cream hunt I I have no problems
with it dude everybody deserves a second
three months and what was his deal he's
the guy who like ran towards a chick and
he hit his friend and then the friend
hit the girl and knocked the girl down
he kicked her did he kick her yeah he
kicked her that he's on video kicking
her it was a hotel party Wow we're not
talking vandal e silva Soccer kicking
somebody's [ __ ] head let's watch it
you make a call yeah pull up the video
if you can video John I'm very
controversial nobody's talking about
this is the hallway I actually know this
hotel right I don't know what happened
there that's him right there yeah this
is good audio for the podcast listeners
oh look at that I mean like dude he went
Phil Dawson I know you think that he's
worth not getting a second chance ever
well to his defense she called him the N
word according to her according to her
yeah he came out and said that the 19
year old I think the whole story Johnny
do you know story and then all the way
in that's what happened see so the girl
said something stupid the other girl
white girl okay hey and this way this is
what happens when you go through life
and nobody's punch you in the face to
let you know that you shouldn't
disrespect [ __ ] people you know I'm
saying like dude you don't hit chicks
but we never tell women don't hit dudes
because some dudes hit back wait I think
they're getting it worse the other women
are getting like westerholt
Neal Brennan swathi bit about the least
to worry about yeah other women are
literally getting like swung and put why
are we not talking about that I mean
that doesn't that's not a big deal
whatever that is I don't know the back
story well here they were 19 and they
weren't allowed they were getting thrown
out in some controvert I don't know
exactly what happened we want to blow
the rich guy to try to get pregnant so
we can have [ __ ] a paycheck they're so
silly kicked
yeah for sure where's the me to move in
on that Josh Gordon was punished more
for kicking weed yeah he got a ring by
the way they should
I'm really sad he couldn't get together
I mean like I mean like you blew it dude
you had all the gifts in the world
listen he's gonna be back next year no
can't play now because of this no he
just got signed by Cleveland and people
around freaking the [ __ ] out yeah I was
like Michael they came back though after
the dogs that's they was playing for the
Eagles when he can't get back in the
lead was playing for the Eagles and then
they traded Michael Vick for Mark
Sanchez which is good because Mark
Sanchez would never hit a dog especially
if he was wide open going across the
middle Chad you're out give it a penalty
box
again this is why we need to make some
that counts the amount of words that
fight nanny says because I think she's
going for a record on this this I feel
like is me talking a lot love it
blabbermouth come on you're sensitive
about a woman getting kicked by a guy
and you just told a woman she can't talk
okay piccolo and you Sam you know he
laid bro pick a leg you're looking truck
driver I can't do it they can't do it
shut up I was a drunk driver yes
you know dude I just saw the Twitter
suggest we file dr. ken please follow
dr. ken let's support him I think he
should be the host of the Oscars I say
sir anyone better than dr. ken the host
the Oscars he's so [ __ ] funny so
what's going on with dr. ken why is he
all of a sudden a big thing I don't know
he's been in major move white 18 years
yeah but what is he gonna do he's a
[ __ ] doctor okay he had fine she
[ __ ] hammer up toots not looking at
anybody succeeding I'm by the way you
guys put in his dues yeah I was doing
doctor duty and [ __ ] doing late night
yeah
how many duty I mean again [ __ ] work
disaster I said just duty all the time
he's [ __ ] pooping constantly dude so
you're trying to get people to rally
behind him he's good he's got a fanbase
you look like a million followers I
think we can take that follow back yeah
no we support we support here we
supported me he needs a doctor Ken ho
special let's go to the phones let's go
the phones thank you buddy calling what
is the phone number here by the way okay
put on screen see if we get some phone
calls uh what else we talking about we
are what do you guys want to get into
whatever forget broke what else I mean
like football we I mean what Oh Russell
Westbrook sets a new triple-double
record him in Paul George man there that
I think they're going to the finals I
don't think they are but I don't know
why they won't trade for Blake Griffin
it's just like they're acting like his
salary is insane it's not that crazy if
you take like Steven Adams and one other
junk guy and you [ __ ] God they need a
[ __ ] third guy and Blake Griffin
would be perfect there but of course
they never do it each time well
Chamberlain's run of nine triple-double
games in a row
yeah sixty-year-old right but I'd like
that yeah it's a fifty-year-old record
that's great yeah like it was like Wilt
Chamberlain versus the dude who's the
milkman during the day you know what I'm
saying like Bob delivers your mouth and
now he's covering [ __ ] will to
Chamberlain
you're right after they used to smoke on
the court problem of Lenny Dawson is in
the locker room between have a nice puff
of a cigarette
hey you find that Dominique Wilkins
thing and not show it but listen to it
dude you have to listen to this video
and you can call hominid quill kins
talking stories about Michael Jordan and
Larry Bird it's the [ __ ] greatest
thing and it's and if you watch this you
go oh this is why I hate LeBron James
because LeBron James killed this go just
go do God and you could call him three
two three eight two seven four two four
alright let's let's play this video I
want to hear this yeah go just go do
what Chuck DS Twitter and find it it's
up there
it's so good dude and you're like you're
like holy [ __ ] are you okay can you hear
it
well you think I mean via migrants I
don't wear them unless
remember that time I almost died at an
aneurysm for news headphones you did and
also this one's broken so you guys give
me the broke I don't blame you just
coming in one ear and going out the
other well it's like tape do you see it
so literally falls off so it doesn't
attach to your crooked they're lopsided
all things how many doesn't have any
money builder on the line to fix it they
just got coffee at this point so let's
just be positive you know where is it
where's this video where's this video
three around we're Malcolm X Huck mad
[ __ ] well Chuck D tweets like a maniac
yeah I love it yeah we got to get him on
the show actually I work on it I'm
calling I'm like why I don't see you
dialing right now okay boom boom guys
this moment of [ __ ] silence is
brought to you by our good friends what
just happened there I wanna know what
the moment of silence was for it's
brought to you by our good friends at
caveman coffee
caveman coffee dude for all your coffee
needs yes I am drinking Starbucks but
you know I'm kicked off again coffee bro
go to caveman coffee I was wearing a
caveman coffee sweater this morning my
baby spit up all over it
well isn't that no it's a good rack hey
caveman coffee sweatshirts good for
jerking off go to caveman coffee calm
use the promo code punch-drunk and you
will get 15% off of all your coffee
needs they got everything legal okay
that'd get you going coffee teas shirts
mugs everything go and they're part of a
friend of the show take Fletcher's and
he's building an empire so let's help
him out it's an independent person
trying to make a difference in his
community he's thinking nationally
acting locally oh look at that
right right right dude no thank you not
interested so we'll find it eventually
are you an MBA guy not nothing that I'm
watch football and you know I mean I'm
keeping an eye on the Sixers because I'm
they're making some moves down there oh
they got a one album brand is killing it
yeah he's so smart he's so a what the
Duke oh my god you see what's going on
Corey Maggette II yeah what the hell is
he doing I just saw headlines
oh my god dude so some people all have
you heard no dude have you heard just
have you heard about what's going on in
Virginia right so this tone comes on
says they found a picture of the
governor ah in blackface like 15 year 20
years ago 25 years like 30 years ago and
like somebody brought this up like who
puts a picture of blackface in a
yearbook like like who's that dumb and
crazy to do that but they did it's in
the yearbook so he got called out well
the guy under him says he should step
down and that he should and he was
become he'll take over so as he's doing
that sex scandal sex scandal comes out
that he's that that he was part of this
rape the guy under him yeah would
replace Hanaka Ralph Shearer Northam in
inver and Virginia as the next incoming
governor he got caught in his own
scandal and then the guy below him who
was gonna take over found out he came
out and said yeah I did wear black for
the party there's a picture of Bill
Clinton and Hillary Clinton and
Hillary's in blackface which was the
only time the Bill Clinton was ever
really sexually attracted to her and she
was in blackface but I mean like I mean
I'm so crazy how insensitive people were
crazy but the thing is we gotta quit
reprimanding these people from things in
the past it was a different time things
were different right time changes jello
or truth oh yeah I hate retroactive
outrage yeah they tried Louie when he
was on that Ricky Gervais show I was
like yeah it was on it was out there
yeah he's sitting with [ __ ] Chris
Rock who did a bit that white people
don't hate black people they hate oh
dude here it is dude can we listen to
this speech okay stop it and that let's
finish this rap so so this guy below him
tries to call him out well some
political should happen and I don't know
where sexual rape charges are pinned are
basically set against him right you
so said against him so then I don't know
where this chick who accused him and
what she says is like we know what
happened you before she says that this
guy raped her and said that we know what
happened before
and we know you won't say anything
because what happened before and what
she's referring to
according to if you put the piece
together is that she would allegedly and
I hate saying it cuz I love the guy so
much but she's got raped by Corey
Maggette II the one year that she was
that Duke whoa
and that Duke told her stop it don't
bring it up don't talk about it cuz he
was a star player yeah who's coming off
the bench which is really weird yeah so
and by the way his nickname in NBA do
you know what Corey McKenna knees
nickname was in the NBA
what bad porn cuz there's loss scoring
but you didn't like what you were
watching you know what I'm saying yeah
bad porn yeah bad porn so this is what
there are this is she I she accused of
that and that's what's coming out and
it's just this weird thing now we get
accused of charging him for rape no he's
got he's getting accused of being a
being a rapist
well she's silent no more I mean she
feels empowered I mean women have to be
believed well they have to don't they
have to Brett Kavanaugh don't they have
to be believed
that's another tinfoil hat that was
enough friend in the thing but I know
you know it's like here we go
now it's like we have a legal system now
let's play this others okay before we
get to that don't put it on the screen I
don't want people to see because just
get Jimi Schubert cuz won't we get flack
for this okay all right and why did you
say why did LeBron James ruin this and
before we get it can we put a pin will
do a teaser
I watched the latest episode of crashing
I don't know if you've seen it
oh I it's the [ __ ] worst thing we'll
put a pin in it why why did you bring it
up here because it's at ease at ease bro
no no I'm curious Sam never changes the
subject of are we talking 15 things and
once you're like anyway yeah back to the
football game ADHD it's called a great
comic it's called a callback I'm working
different things
comic
of crashing I can't help if my mind is a
choose-your-own-adventure okay I can't
watch this is crashing thing but let's
get this there yeah we'll be back
this is the best lot of young kids
without would be a great athlete where
that's your first mistake a great
athlete can give you a lot of oohs and
ahhs great basketball player gonna beat
you every night
wait till you it's too bad story I
remember the first time I played I'm
working in playing against the Boston
Celtics in the Boston Garden
no shake and Larry put both hands behind
his back we're in Sigma that's okay he's
just getting into the game first play
the game anything you know he belong in
the lead home and he shoots at three now
I wouldn't mad that he made the three
but I said there's something it's just
called me home and he and you came to I
did again so I'm pissed you know so next
time down see me one to bring their
pitching I jump up and I throw it down
on a man I mean he fouls me and you say
hey rook I like you you got hot he said
what I'm still getting 30 or your ass
that's who he was but that was all honey
you ready stop it's my Terry stop talk
trash to me because he respected me
because he knew that I was gonna keep
coming that really taught me something
you know if you wasn't prepared to play
against guys like that you got
embarrassed Larry at 60 gets us one game
in New Orleans I don't forget that game
Moosa was hot he started shooting threes
with his left hand
stop that I mean he was stop that whoa
start sure he was so hot he was shooting
threes with his left hand like do people
think that LeBron James would wipe the
floor with Larry Bird no and it's like
dude he played a guy that was equally
athletic
maybe a tiny bit smaller but equally
athletic and let him the [ __ ] up yeah if
you give Larry Bird's today's trainers
and nutritionists and flight schedules
and coddling a per diem he would be
unbelievable did I love the 34:30 with
magic and and Larry Bird that goes all
the way back to college and just how
they drove each other and like how
amazing they were like like it's like
the Frazier on order for me to be in
Frazier there had to be an online course
there for the beadle area but they
played each other a joke yeah but it all
goes all the way back to college because
oh yeah they beat him in [ __ ] college
for the [ __ ] yeah I know Ford it's
like that rivalry they went into the
NBA's and I mean I love that stuff they
didn't communicate until like 84 like
they'd already were the NBA for four
years they had no communication until
they filmed the converse commercial in
French Lick and that's when they
actually started to communicate and talk
and realize okay they're pretty he's a
pretty cool guy
they'd hated each other on e hit it
again there's more weight here this
mutton that's Michael Jordan's story
dude it's the [ __ ] bad one
he had you can show it [ __ ] it who care
in the heart of a lion and he didn't
like anybody and he never showed again
this isn't the Joe Rogan experience
we're not getting kicked off never shook
hands and it just pushes you to have
that same toughness in that same
attitude and we had some epic battles I
ran into him at the Hall of Fame about a
mutton hand for gone I said Larry you
know something man
so all these years competing you know
known each other we've never taken a
picture so we took our first picture
together I love that old men tell
stories for [ __ ] hours yeah it's a
different is this showing respect and
appreciation for the area you played in
you know I got a one of magic I got
Moses Michael I mean look these are
these are the guys I competed against
man I mean this will battle with all
about so I'm just paying respect to
those these guys did this Michael
Jordan's story
first time I played against Michael was
in college he was a freshman and the
game went back and forth back and forth
close game all went through in the last
two minutes there's young kid they might
be Jordan you won the game it was and I
said then I said he gonna be a hell of a
player as a freshman and his attitude
his mentality kill everybody he was a he
was a killer you know he wanted to take
your heart out I would never forget this
I never had a player to do this this is
in going my sponsors Chicago and their
wind suit and tie we're sitting in
Lockland we just walking a lock on now
remember Michael Jordan walks into our
locker room soon died I'm like hell is
he doing our locker when was he coming
to you know to the training room well I
wasn't going on so he walks by me he
walks by Kevin we get to rainy witness a
lace him up is gonna be a long night
dude stopping right there how great is
that just gonna walk he dude he walked
into their locker room and go lace them
up it's gonna be a long [ __ ] night
like that to me is what you want in your
[ __ ] competition do you want these
guys to kill each other
LeBron James killed all that LeBron want
sleepovers together there's no hard
[ __ ] fouls because we all got make
that paper and like what you're seeing
is like LeBron and that [ __ ] touch
buck crew starting to [ __ ] fade out
and these Joel embiid just [ __ ]
talking mad [ __ ] to everybody I missed
that yeah dude it's like but no but all
that all that everything's changed now I
mean it's not like in like hockey in the
early 70s was like yeah I mean you you
know you what's the old joke you're
watching guys do 15 to 20 years or
something you're getting five minutes
yeah this guy's heist I like I mean yeah
by the way the Flyers took to [ __ ] is
Stanley Cup by force
Rick McLeish at 263 [ __ ] penalty
minutes
in a [ __ ] year like literally this is
[ __ ] you know and you go to like that
crew that is 70 73 74 they didn't win
the 75 but 76 they came back but I mean
just that era of sports is like when you
go and now you watch
and you know like my I [ __ ] love I
wish the NBA would have like a [ __ ]
enforcer rule yeah okay like one guy
five years in a row like a cut like to
milk
yeah and he's there with you you know
we're like to do any NFL award as retro
uniforms [ __ ] the retro yours
why don't you play retro football kid
with one [ __ ] single bar go to cross
your cake I mean you gotta sell
insurance in the offseason sixty minutes
on both sides of the ball like people
like realize like you look at this
[ __ ] guys who played in the 60s these
[ __ ] played on both sides of
the football
yeah offense and defense [ __ ] one
dude was kicking field goals
it was kicking the field goal three
would run the point and Paul Hornung was
like he kicked a couple extra and they
had farmer strength yeah they didn't
have protein and yeah farm boy pipes
dude farmer strength dude I'll take
farmer strength vs. HGH any day
give me a dude on HGH with puffy muscles
versus guy who's been fighting grizzly
bear to leave his cattle alone every
take that guy every NFL player look like
Greg Warren yeah and then they get that
mentally encumbered strategy to episode
it's how we got it is okay I talked
about it earlier but the to show
crashing all the produced by Judd Apatow
and Pete Holmes they release an episode
yesterday no no it gets more
uncomfortable okay
now before this there's a Jamie Lee the
comic goes on stage he's emceeing and
she basically is makes fun of burns this
whole set making fun because he it's
it's somewhat misogynistic and he's
talking about hooking up with chicks and
and they it's it's filmed at the West
Nyack location they call it the chuckle
hunt and then Dov goes up and he's
trying to do his jokes and the crowds
just looking at him they're shaking
their heads they're booing and he's just
like a rock-and-roll comic he likes to
have shots afterwards and afterwards
they're in the parking like those days
are over
okay it's a different era and it was the
most uncomfortable [ __ ] episode I go
it's doesn't speak for comedians I don't
know why you guys are shoving this
agenda down people's throats definitely
go watch it just so you could punch
somebody oh now you know what the thing
is it's [ __ ] you know the thing is
like people go I was having this I was
on back in New York and some guys as
well well don't you think do you feel
like I go no cuz the only [ __ ] gauge
is whether someone's actually funny or
not
you just think how many clubs or
businesses people [ __ ] pay money to
come in there and [ __ ] laugh and the
problem of this occupation is you don't
get that good till you got 20 [ __ ]
years in and you can't just go [ __ ]
changing the rules just be could you say
that the [ __ ] world is burning like
the audience dictates what the [ __ ] I
talk about because they're [ __ ]
laughing at it I mean you can't I mean
you can't [ __ ] create art like that
that's ridiculous I'm [ __ ] ridiculous
Apatow is a [ __ ] Benedict Arnold to
what we [ __ ] do
he's been got cheat codes to get where
he is his family's high up in
entertainment he's [ __ ] a trust fund
kid and now he's coming in and he's
doing this [ __ ] agenda [ __ ] we always
know we don't even need to watch Judd
Apatow [ __ ] shows or see his tweets
to know what his take is and it's across
the board at one point anybody what
white guy with a dick is evil no matter
what this isn't he a white guy with a
dick yeah but dude and then look Marty
does the same [ __ ] and no silence at one
point they're all saying in the comedy
condo together dub David offs a
headliner did they demoted him to
feature act because they got complaints
on the comment cards so they promote
Pete Holmes to head
so he's you know the never never happens
and he comes back to the comedy condo
after he has a killer set and they're
drinking tea he goes what the [ __ ] is
this it's go do some shots let's hang
out what am i doing she goes you can go
do some shots we're drinking tea oh my
god dude that is that is versatile just
warrior where you the real problem is
bro the problem is they get the
headliner stay in the condo that never
happened yeah I'd stay in the condo his
dick would be okay with this show going
on I don't know why Doug Davidoff would
take that role enough money but didn't
you see on the show yeah he's like a
reoccurring yeah well they just killed
that character oh no he may be lever or
awakening come out and do jokes about
socks misses from his dryer okay all who
are afraid of [ __ ] the truth that the
game is a hard game and you got to work
we're gonna [ __ ] support this thing
and the people who grind by the way the
women who are huge in comedy for the
most part not 100% but for the most part
are not the ones co-signing this me to
[ __ ] they're now up there crying
about how hard it is to be them they
[ __ ] grind everyone's you know that
they don't got what it takes to actually
go are trying to create bumper bowling
comedy which is like put the bumpers in
the gutter so I can't get gutters so I
can [ __ ] do this it's like the
alternative cooking comedy movement back
in the [ __ ] day it's like you know I
I grew up watching the [ __ ] best of
the best
it was [ __ ] jokes it was your writing
was punchline punchline punchline and
now you got a [ __ ] 15-minute story
with some kind of writing [ __ ] move
[ __ ] one punch line and I go cool
[ __ ] who does comedy like that man
[ __ ] get you [ __ ] what do you think
would be more pissed if you said male
comics can't date female comics who do
you think would lose their [ __ ] more
female cop female comics why why because
how many of them [ __ ] dick riders on
these [ __ ] guys making it huge and
getting opening spots that their talent
doesn't really warm
good I want to know how many female
comics have [ __ ] male comics as
writers on their feet are [ __ ]
writing their [ __ ] call in like you got
Bonnie McFarlane who's a [ __ ] real
Genie christina pazsitzky Sarah Tiana
and I go on to these real people who
write their own [ __ ]
but you know what a lot of these [ __ ]
barking they got [ __ ] mail writers
that's a [ __ ] unseen truth and you
know this isn't Jimmy Schubert saying
this this is me and Chad sumac saying
hey it's the [ __ ] truth dude how many
chicks have [ __ ] male writers nobody
talks about it
they're all [ __ ] saying the [ __ ] and
then secretly the runners dicks to write
their jokes
how many comics have [ __ ] guys to get to
the top that's true [ __ ] true all
female comics but this play orating
[ __ ] going on it's trying to ruin
comedy because well yeah you know the
problem is it's really [ __ ] tough to
do well it's really tough to do with a
high level you don't get the [ __ ] you
don't get to cheat that but I love about
[ __ ] comedy is a great equalizer you
can't you could you could fake it some
night you can fool some of the people
some of the time you can fool all the
people so but you can't fool everybody
all the time you gotta put in the
[ __ ] dude I was [ __ ] sleeping in
my [ __ ] car in a rest area 54 miles
from Missoula Montana because I was on a
[ __ ] Tribble run [ __ ] freezing and
slept in my car with the [ __ ] heater
was barely [ __ ] like it was a little
old lady blowing up the hot air I had to
sleep my car but I mean the grind of
[ __ ] doing this for years and [ __ ]
traveling and dry you felt like a truck
driver driving your car didn't have
[ __ ] GPS we had [ __ ] Rand McNally
maps we have used [ __ ] pay phone I
didn't think about that
pick up yet and I did the shoot I once
had to use the Stars to figure out going
talk of Magellan that's [ __ ]
hilarious
my [ __ ] told me my old man was driving
pulls out a [ __ ] map and a microphone
or no microphone with a magnifying glass
mangling [ __ ] Magellan relax all
right let me pop it into my nude I think
comedy is fine there's a lot of great
female comics out jessica Kherson is a
crusher
sadly manager I dare any of these female
comics to follow them I dare you not out
there crying about this [ __ ] it's the
girls barking the most that [ __ ] got
male writers writing for why don't you
name some I know say don't you yeah why
I feel like you're not the industry
don't get that don't get this think I'm
I'm gonna get a ton of [ __ ] for this or
I'm maybe not even important I I they
don't even give a [ __ ] about me but the
point is it's like this [ __ ] that's
going on right now I just [ __ ] trust
fund kids dude everything that you hate
about comedy Judd Apatow has had a
[ __ ] hand in it
you hate the [ __ ] sacred victim [ __ ]
everybody gets a chance Judd Apatow [ __ ]
you hate nerd beta kook nerds [ __ ]
Judd Apatow you'll a [ __ ] elitist
[ __ ] white female actresses and
comics crop born on third base crying
about how they can't hit [ __ ]
homeruns
[ __ ] Judd Apatow all that [ __ ] and I
don't hate judge but I'm just getting
tired of this man it's like you're
killing the you're trying to snuff out
the profession yeah for a guy like you
know they're also the thing you gotta
realize is I mean you know he's I mean I
would [ __ ] Shandling steak on a beer
or any of these guys that like you know
Kinnison or [ __ ] Pryor what would
their take on a B I'm sure these guys
all supported freaking female come on
comedians I have on my I've actually get
good taking girls in the row with me and
something you know shared a condom with
them was nothing more than a gentleman
ever I mean you come up with these
[ __ ] things like men are [ __ ] I go
that I would never [ __ ] make your
[ __ ] journey more difficult because I
know how hard difficult the real journey
is you're not gonna get a difficult time
for me you're gonna get me to [ __ ]
make sure no one [ __ ] gives you a hard
time but that's what way most [ __ ]
comedians most guys with real [ __ ]
talent don't [ __ ] play that most guys
of real talent know how tough this is
and so they're not going to I mean this
creeps out there that are insecure and
they think you may be male maybe funnier
I'm gonna give you a hard time but
that's because they're an insecure
little [ __ ] huge bag yeah I don't
feel that way I don't have any [ __ ]
sisters I'm good lookout for women not
that they need me too but I'm always
[ __ ] do to me make kinds of women bit
of flame throat I'm [ __ ] Twitter and
I jumped in and fought Lisa Leslie
Whitney Cummings
[ __ ] Melissa Villasenor I jumped in
and early I [ __ ] killed people can I
play devil's advocate though you know
jove judd apatow do you think maybe he
made that special for a conversation and
a dialogue do you think maybe that's the
reason why he did it
that show like there isn't a
conversation and dialogue going on yeah
you don't it's like are you just deaf
are you staying at home I'm just saying
I mean you know I just [ __ ] brought
it up about how shitty it is and now
you're just [ __ ] pivoted yeah it's
called good radio podcast [ __ ] it's
not a radio show and furthermore I mean
you know what I've heard this like you
know I'm out there trying to sell my
special now if you don't wanna buy my
special because you don't think it's
good oh this is from a Judd Apatow film
it sounds gay you know this is like the
first conversation of like you're saying
because you Macra made yourself a pair
of jean shorts that's the killer [ __ ]
that Judd Apatow's gave us great comedy
rape though you're gay Dre comedy Judd
Apatow is this Steven Seagal of comedy
where it's like we look back in the 80s
like why did we enjoy this it's so
[ __ ] bad I know smells pretty badass
dude they're they're they're so good cuz
they're so bad now you're like a fat guy
in a [ __ ] karate give items crashing
takes other massages dinosaurs of comedy
who are you talking about who Oh Louis
ganodi I love that [ __ ] Christianity
like unbelievable dude like that is what
is wrong
like you're literally [ __ ] on the
biggest [ __ ] religious that is the
biggest buying power here and that's
when nobody gives a [ __ ] about anything
anymore they're all killing him when he
they were the ones that allowed him to
do what he did
I love Lewis I Love Lucy Jane never did
a thing for me doesn't know who the [ __ ]
I am
yeah I don't listen I mean look the guy
[ __ ] jerked off from the you know her
permission well first off I got news for
you and to his credit I know there's a
picture with those two girls without
their tops on which he never [ __ ] I
must say something about those two girls
they are not the ones that pushed all
this [ __ ] this is a [ __ ] journalist
trying to get a head on a [ __ ] steak
she made it well on a [ __ ] hold on she
she omitted a ton of [ __ ] that Dana and
Julia has said yeah I know them this
whole notion that their careers have
been destroyed by this isn't true
they've gone on and have sanely [ __ ]
gray career starting movies sold TV
shows bidding show runners nobody ever
talks about that they talk about one
chick who's convinced everybody that her
[ __ ] careers ruined because he asked
can i drink in front of you she said no
and he she said they he she scorched the
earth he scorched the earth and got her
fired from her management company I've
been fired by so many managers it's part
of the [ __ ] gig dude okay
go watch that girl special and tell me
if you think it was Lucy Kay that
[ __ ] ruined her career she's just
like all of us [ __ ] working on [ __ ]
but I would love to have a boogie man I
could bling all my [ __ ] problems on
yeah dude I I mean I don't run into dad
I mean I just been told by my
distributor and by my agent that you
know they don't even want to see your
special that you know you're you know
that I was told if you were minority I
go why would you say that because you
know I'm not on mine oh you've seen my
special
did you watch well we watched a couple
minutes so you watched a couple minutes
my special so what you're telling me is
you don't care how funny or how good
special is you care more about what I
look like and so you're doing that to me
but then you're gonna run a [ __ ] about
that are you doing this to everybody
else listen if we live in a meritocracy
if you are a funny female if you're
funny anybody if you're funny then you
should [ __ ] work period it's an
incredibly difficult job to do for
people to put these stipulations on it
and you're a dinosaur and this that and
the other thing is like now it's just
it's that's why it was done I mean you
you couldn't
unless you were [ __ ] funny I can't
you can't give somebody why doesn't lose
CK do a [ __ ] well I mean why is it
judd apatow do an episode on ah [ __ ]
Bryan Singer molesting kids where's that
episode here we go
where's the episode Judd where is it huh
why is he do an episode on the Democrat
guy who killed two gay men black man in
his [ __ ] apartment where's that it's
a judge defense it's a comedy show and I
don't know how Bryan Singer wedges and
Comm producing a new comedy committees
or additional yeah any hey can i [ __ ]
your kids get the part but here's the
thing like I you know I I work with
Godfrey a locker he's a good friend of
my wheat and I go on his radio show and
the best part aim dropper no game drop
it works because got a game dropper is a
black man from Kenya and he comes to
present you shut up ten penalty box
get in it oh my god you gotta be kidding
me yeah you can't yell on show penalty
box
but I'm trying to tell a story she's
just saying Godfrey's your good friend
of yours no screw it I'm going to the
goddamn penny buzzer ruining content
yeah because it's all about you Seth
this shows all about you to those drunk
listeners that who wanted to hear this
great story as about to tell III got to
go to the penalty box because no no Sam
it's a thing it's a thing that's how
brenton knows we're here but I was a
friend called her vagina the penalty box
um why cuz he only goes in for five
minutes listen here's the thing listen
real quick chats walked off another
podcast so he might do it again he
hasn't been here for 14 days 14 days
he's already burned bridges with [ __ ]
Brody Stevens well Brandon he's about to
do Sam Tripoli how do you do it in 14
days because you're Chad [ __ ]
Zuma that's how you do it
where's the timer so I know cuz I'm
enjoy everybody
- Neal Brennan I don't know when you saw
the pain boxing you talked about it I
love Brody is easy to make mad
so that doesn't intrigue me as much yeah
yeah we got a penalty box song now - we
have a penalty box song manners what a
wonderful time to be alive how much oh
[ __ ] just starting now [ __ ] Chad you
might be the longest penalty box of all
time eating your cheese hits over there
who brings cheese into a podcast he
needs something to throw at you bro it's
worse than cheese it's the caca sort of
cheese in the middle that's even worse
it's like little crust in that even is
from run the cheese he made of himself
from scratch yeah he's doing what's that
cheese cheese which makes its own cheese
please crackers puts into the crack of
his balls he sleeps it overnight gets
under and scrapes it out put it on a
cracker
right here this is a sacred victim
turning death threats a new comic book I
get told to kill myself
that piece of [ __ ] all the time on the
Internet yeah you thought even gonna
callus on your feelings yes okay do you
know the penalty boxes started again
yeah - [ __ ]
there we go now we're back up to five
guys - timer okay
okay I'll play again oh here we go
you might want to put that to the side
here we go ready got to hit that on mute
dude
our production values gone the [ __ ]
Jimmy Schubert's wondering what he did
for the last hour why aren't you just
isolate that some point okay well we're
gonna work well yeah I mean were seven
years in this thing I mean we're still
working out the kinks nice back to the
top row what are you talking what do you
want to talk about are the views
expressed about Judd Apatow Sam
troubling symptoms of it oh [ __ ]
Jimmy Schubert's available for anytime
for any kind of role on crashing on HBO
yeah no I'm not you know I'm dead that's
a New York thing I never even get called
in for those things I never like you
know you're doing a show about you know
comedy god forbid you go to the Comedy
Store and and it was like what was that
the show we had a bunch of friends on it
but people go do you watch it not really
because I lived it yeah I didn't even
get called in the guy I mean like I mean
when you talk about sets done at the
Comedy Store like total amount of sets I
gotta be top twenty I've been there for
20 years
yeah you know I mean it's like I was
just talking on my other podcast like
what a blessing it is to be at Mecca for
20 year how long you've been there 30 30
Koby didn't even play for [ __ ] the
Lakers for that much you were at the
Mecca longer than Kobe was a Laker at
Ground Zero when it started before the
big boom of the eighties yeah I've
actually been in been here for you know
the second you know kind of Renaissance
of the comedy stuff yeah I've been
phenomenal it's a wonderful time to be
alive yeah it is you know like you got
some troll from the internet chase you
down telling you to kill yourself yeah I
mean and I got I got my friends that I
got put in penalty box because they
don't just don't understand the flow of
the show he's bringing a Cleveland
attitude to a [ __ ] a top-shelf podcast
not used to this kind of what does he
think's going on bro dude he's just so
nobody got appetizer on the phone for
you bro good for your mind I'd love to
talk to me I don't have any problems
which other
then he's [ __ ] yeah that's my only
problem with that guy didn't you guys
fight on Twitter already no no I laid
into them and he was released no he
didn't I thought he did I thought he
quotes we did you know he didn't it no
oh it was you quote tweeting him yeah
yeah well no it's just stupid that whole
virtues singing like oh you're better
than everybody else just like dude
meanie bad guy you know it's like dude
everybody's grinding if I hear another
person complain about how they were
treated at an open mic yeah we all got
treated like [ __ ] open mic that's why
you get better not to do that [ __ ]
that's the price that penalty is you
deal with these [ __ ] low-level trolls
didn't get up here's what you do
if you don't like it there you go
somewhere [ __ ] else it's just the way
it is
yeah well that's not that's not the
world we live in bro well me and you
were dinosaurs in this business but we
need that we yeah I'm a t-rex talking
about tiny arms I can't touch myself
whichever what we can't do we're done
people have weighed in dude we've got to
get out of the business now make way for
this ng your stuff that's coming [ __ ]
it's what said to your dude no soy boy
[ __ ] what I'm saying is it's soy boys
[ __ ] like everybody else is loud to bees
[ __ ] honestly they can white guy goes
up there and it's just like oh my god
what is this [ __ ] clan meeting it's
just like dude it's like there's a
reason why black comics are selling out
places cuz then go up there say anything
they want they're the most real [ __ ] you
up then do some real [ __ ] [ __ ] you
hear bubbles going click click click
click get you tighter you're like dude
yeah it's really kind of like walk in a
minefield today because there's only
something but I but actually made me a
better writer
I actually write around all the [ __ ]
I really do I'm gonna you know I'm gonna
have 45 minutes and if you get upset at
my show you're a frickin [ __ ] but yeah
but but my shits really funny but I was
like the other night I went up at the El
Cid with Alexa Foxx and who's that other
girls name that the porn star of this
comedy whatever but we were doing that
the highest Fox show over there and then
everybody's out there doing filthy [ __ ]
and I went out and just I can drop like
[ __ ] 10 minutes a clean [ __ ] and
[ __ ] destroyed look at Jasmine that's
been the byproduct of this whole thing
from and another by practice the hashtag
me too I don't save so much money in
dinner and drinks oh yeah cuz I ain't
buying [ __ ] for [ __ ]
call them for a moratorium of monthly
male comics and female comics no no for
you drink I'm not gonna listen I'm gonna
go I'm gonna back to my [ __ ] hotel
room I'm gonna jerk off like [ __ ]
MiG's from silence and Lam and toss a
little toddler juice into a tissue of
love
there'll be no [ __ ] hash tag Jimmy
Schumer me too that haiku I think there
was a haiku so it was about a video it
was a filthy I go ya need to be specials
on white guys though cuz in it if I'm
just gonna watch women and like African
American comedies that I don't really
understand you know what I mean it's
like I actually need to hear ye comics
it's actually not that shitty that like
white people white guys are so bad how
come they're remaking all their ideas as
[ __ ] chick so many people say that
like we don't like we'd also did a lot
of good [ __ ] you know like invent a
laptop and the [ __ ] our cell phone
and and [ __ ] like laws of this
country you know what I mean the
constant there was something [ __ ] that
we did that was good I mean we're not
you know so like I said what's wrong
with this country is such a [ __ ]
ignorant [ __ ] dumb thing to [ __ ]
say proving to me number one that you've
never been outside the United States
[ __ ] ever and you haven't run a real
[ __ ] history book in your entire
[ __ ] life that lets me know that I
will know your back out bro tell us your
story Chad I'm so glad you're back oh my
back's killing me from carrying this
thing now that was actually a good setup
for my album you can get on iTunes a
white guy named Chad how about that
technically we created all this we said
we created that let the laptop the cell
phone because of these devices it became
what it is we're the ones that created
the monster we gave them this
information we're Twitter like how like
nothing would happen without a man and
then like he goes into it yeah it's a
good bet yeah I mean that's that's a
great [ __ ] point and you know what
you know you undermine I mean those guys
died on the beach at Normandy otherwise
everybody's speaking [ __ ] German
right now yeah you know I mean you can't
you can't just [ __ ] say cuz you're an
ignorant [ __ ] doesn't mean that the
whole [ __ ] world news I go
[ __ ] history but get back to me Chad
you had a story to tell before you went
weird yeah yeah I forgot it must have
been pretty much too busy eating those
crackers right in your phone while you
were tweeting hey remember this story
well I you derailed the hog conversation
it was a momentum killer so I can't go
back don't know if you missed but we
were just crushing right now in a great
store I don't know a penalty parking off
that's called [ __ ] podcast goal don't
know what happens on radio so we don't
do radio we say about your friend
Godfrey go oh it's off topic it's not
gonna work no story Godfrey comes he's
uh african-american he comes from to
educators his father was a professor his
mother was a professor a family of three
they were above inch above income
average home right I'm a white guy named
Chad you know you would think that would
be my life no I come from a
single-parent household never met my dad
we were low-income my mom my dad with
that I met your dad what he was running
this [ __ ] donkey show
Mexico soon we were in a we were we were
a chat I hate Chad meeting yeah I hate
Chad him to a prison go on Chad but
we're just going like judging somebody
like my backstory is rough but I'm a
white dude named Chad you would think my
life's privileged but I had a horrible
up bring a tough upbringing where how
godfrey had this amazing guy ringing
it's the problem with the punch up punch
down yeah because you assume you'll know
who this person is and therefore you
know they are where they're punching
from yes don't like what I call it as it
this is unearned familiarity yeah
with people that follow you on social
media think just because you tweet it oh
I know this guy I know this guy they
think you're fine it's like no you know
nothing more about me than my name you
don't know what I do you don't know my
life's like you can assume that you know
those things but you don't you don't
know you know that the charity work the
things you do when you're not on camera
things you're not versus England give me
your pass of a pat on the back for
because it's not what
you're [ __ ] doing it for but all that
stuff all the good things you doing like
go quietly by and then people just want
to make a [ __ ] judgment call on Sam
Tripoli guy works harder than ugly
stripper up here he doesn't I worked
hard to that's hard I'm like this is the
blow now [ __ ] but you can see for a
dollar I agree he does look like an ugly
stripper no get up there look at that
[ __ ] Harry Morse plug it is all
[ __ ] game all your [ __ ] shave
throw me a bone up in it bro get up get
up in there and push that clump of
grapes back in that [ __ ] hairy
monster yeah I mean like dude I mean at
the end of the day everybody's grinded
and I think these these these
generalizations that you're I mean
people want like you see people want a
credit for oppression they never went
through women they're talking about oh
we couldn't both 50 years ago you don't
vote now unless it's American Idol you
don't give a [ __ ] no I do like every
woman votes because not rude all my
friends are annoying about it
Hillary Clinton did it vote the women
did not go out and vote for she and get
blacks she get women who [ __ ]
basically got Obama in it's just the
truth and then you have female comments
going on talk shows talking about Bernie
Sanders step down and you find out that
girl didn't even vote they didn't vote
if they didn't vote for her though
well it does that's what she says they
must have not voted for me because their
husbands have brutalizing yeah like I
can't even [ __ ] I just I I think
they're all so full of [ __ ] [ __ ] I
can't even [ __ ] listen I got rid of
my [ __ ] cable box I got why I clipped
it out I said come get this [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] why do you think
they call it programming because you're
sit there and get manipulated by the
mainstream media and none of its fact
none of its true hey dude look your
mansplaining right now to her please
okay Dana actually watches like CNN all
day long and gets angry it's like you
can't watch that stuff Dana that's like
[ __ ] argument politics or somebody
wants to CNN it's like discussing
physics with a professor from Clown
College
yeah for sure by all means let's get
into it dude no you know what they said
the way all gone nobody had to retract
15 [ __ ] 20 stories now go ahead and
they don't care nobody cares he was
doing
and do you know what dude you don't want
mansplaining ladies okay
so when you're dating your boyfriend and
for the hundredth time you tell them
stop the movie and explain you what's
going on that's going to we do
understand another movie or TV show
again if I [ __ ] stop man's playing to
her what the [ __ ] going on I knew that
that's mansplaining I'm on your side
euphy mansplaining okay ladies man's
going back to what sam says get out and
vote this WNBA all-stars you got Sue
Bird you got Breanna Stewart
Tina Charles get out and vote your vote
counts the WNBA is that we get yeah I'd
love to w anybody there's no so many
empty seats they can do things like
bring your dog tough to a game nice how
many empty [ __ ] seats like we'll see
during the halftime on but why don't
female support their own I don't know to
the W guys they're not really females
huh yeah I gotta tell you I watched a
WNBA I get an inverted boner my body and
ice yeah but I'm just saying I don't
like I like I like feminine women I
don't look [ __ ] butchered troops walk
Road chuckling [ __ ] with dudes I'll hang
out with dudes if I want to see that I
want a [ __ ] feminine woman but if we
might want to be a part of football and
basketball they want to be sad like why
aren't they like embracing their own
that's what I'm saying but look with
this look what happens you let them in
the [ __ ] Boy Scouts not to have an
all-female [ __ ] Boy Scout you only
know men allowed give you an itch and
you want a whole foot yeah isn't this a
small amount of women that like sports
oh I feel like most women don't watch
basketball you know I've been watching
this [ __ ] show on Amazon Prime called
scorn you watch the show but these women
who go out and [ __ ] [ __ ] her
husband's then they divorced her husband
and then they murdered her [ __ ] you
watch 3d0 you I'm never gonna go near
her hey ever again I mean look I very
rarely beat off but what I do I like to
use a woman's vagina I don't beat off
but when I do when I do I like to use
hey dude if you want like most
maury povich stories are like this chick
cheated on her husband and she's like
you showed me it nuttin he never showed
me attends he's like I was working three
jobs what do you want me to do yeah well
you want me to do
I was working three fun no dude you
don't I'm glad I've never married I'm
[ __ ] glad I'm glad I'm so five watch
that I got Jesus and there's his other
show on Amazon I got caught in less they
called killers behind the myth
I'm telling you what street these guys
we're [ __ ] killing like like eight
year old babies and eating your flesh
yeah and I got now I don't feel so bad
about Jimmy's Who I am I see you Sam I'm
working three jobs today you don't give
me any credit okay talk to me what are
the job well I'm here okay I have to go
to work right now what do you hate how
many jobs you got me oh I thought you
were asking Ted you looked at Chad when
you call you see how I was again call a
Skype call guys I got a guy some guy who
just sent me an Instagram message Shane
the phones aren't working the phones
aren't working from god damnit Chad god
dammit yeah it's Chad so is anybody I
know you're not big basketball are you
guys enjoying the crash and burn of
LeBron James right now well I'll let
Jimmy go he's our guest yeah I I am I
mean I'm not even a I'm not really a fan
I mean I don't I'm just think that
wherever that guy goes is like he just
dominates and like it's all about him
and it's like you know I mean he's a
great player I people caught on that he
allows his teammate to be destroyed in
the media yeah and doesn't stand up for
me yeah cause they can't win with look I
tried look I tried look you can't you
can't won with a guy like that it's like
you can't win with guys like just
selfish pleasure it's like Colin
Kaepernick you can't want a guy like
that on your team so so when the
newscasters talking about what you're
doing off the field rather than when
you're on the field quite quite fair
it's about what you're doing on the
[ __ ] day if they're talking about
what you're doing on how great you are
on the court then that's one thing we
want to talk about all this other [ __ ]
yeah you know I don't give a [ __ ] I
don't want to look I don't hear your
politics I don't hear you nobody talked
about Dirk Nowitzki Tim Duncan but his
teammates they nobody ever said anything
bad about him but LeBron it's just chaos
yeah
he gambled and lost he [ __ ] on his
entire team passively aggressively and
when that trade didn't happen he had to
go into a [ __ ] locker room of
everybody who can't stand him right now
right now he has two franchises and I
hate his guts Cleveland and the Lakers
it's a bad situation to be it yeah yes
he's a piece of [ __ ] yeah I don't even
care I don't even care that you're like
you know one of the best players if
you're a piece of [ __ ] in your [ __ ]
life you know and so I don't even get
zero attention zero zero [ __ ] about
them zero tau 0 jokes that's right and
you can get those all have you gonna do
websites our website I mean Magic
Johnson can't stop shutting up they got
a Palmas I go and dude you are the
[ __ ] GM you can't talk about after
we've been busted constantly trying to
poach peoples players and the empresa
team's like [ __ ] you dude dude and then
Elton Brand got him we have them
investigate because Mac John's like yeah
I want to meet within him and teach him
about tall point guard skills and that
comes from Ben Simmons basically
reaching out to everybody all these
legends about learning the sport but
dude you've been busted doing basically
[ __ ] tampering and people I love the
[ __ ] mainstream you go oh
Judy's Jeff why why is this issue I
don't know because the other teams don't
want you taking their franchise players
because [ __ ] ESPN is once again
ruining a sport because their ratings
are down yeah the ratings are down
because they're doing the MBA what they
did the baseball which making five teams
all that [ __ ] is being cares about
and these small markets are dying yeah
should morons have a team we don't know
but dude you're killing them right yeah
it's like yeah it's like Netflix we're
coming it's like you know nobody it's a
good analogy with a ESPN do we want with
sports Netflix in comedy it's yeah I
mean you know they're trying to create
[ __ ] this you know everybody agree 9
yeah what do you sit on es manufactured
consent because I just I was just at the
Comedy Store and I met up name-dropper
rich
[Music]
every time my trying to make a point I
get interrupted by everybody it's just
it's ridiculous so you wanted the call
yes I go to the phones but daddy I
didn't know you had to it would take
over the whole all the audio who's
online so we gotta call her they're
calling themselves leaving shows up
anything you want to blow it alone to go
nanny other kill mom remember I said
Jeff brings her to me so me and her can
nannies again it's a fellow
ten-month-old it's so cute everything
you want to plug plug comedy chaos but
it's already sold out I'm sorry sold out
oh so the 25th with Jimmy Schubert the
26 I'm Maddie
you want to meet me cuz I'm just so
famous come to hear 26 and get my own
shirts of yours if we sell like - yeah
you know what I never got a shirt it
really hurts me you go weirdos coming up
to you and I don't know because you guys
weren't giving me money and so like a
month ago
t-ball you guys I did do you got weirdos
coming up to you from the punch are we
gonna sell yeah a lot when are we gonna
hey Johnny hi one closer we to the
website going up in shirt sales but I
just still isn't up two weeks thoughts
two weeks he's trying to work i watch we
just I know how long to the might the
websites up yeah don't blame him to
triplet you're like really bad okay I
love when these do you're saying two
weeks it's two weeks so you can't blame
people can I get another shirt can I get
another chance I want to say man if we
had five minutes left I throw you back
into penalty but yeah we don't even have
five minutes left
yeah yeah
what's your DUI I liked the shirt we had
I also like the brontosauruses shirt
because I like dinosaurs and also [ __ ]
baby likes throwing up on those shirt
every shirt I'm that sure but I don't
have mine so she'll never believe me
that I was on the show my dog hates the
show everyone hates us you think he let
me do not everyone hates the show that's
why they show up late and don't show up
at all and they leave early the
podcasting is you're gonna podcasting
against your will this has been a
hostage situation
um Johnny Annie what else you had
something to say okay all right so we
got a basketball it's the greatest year
ever a basketball I mean like I miss the
old Jordan days but this is getting
climene like the East is nuts the East
is not so I was done LeBron's gotta be
happy got out there cuz he would have
gotten house by all these super teams
dude he's created this NBA the super
team member who's like where do you
think the Sixers follow up in the east
of I mean dude they got a legit squad
except for the cook and the starting
five the rest of them are [ __ ]
murderers yeah Tobias Harris went to the
right place you know for you you're a
number two option on great team now
you're [ __ ] number four on a killer
team it's [ __ ] great yeah so you
think that's gonna be a tough division
no I gotta be a tough team to beat yeah
I went to a Philly game
caspere's Philly last year when LeBron
played for the Cavs I was in Philly
I had a Cavs shirt on and I swear to god
I'm walking down and a guy goes take
that shirt off
[ __ ] right in Philly that's the kind
of fans they got out welcome to Philly
bro yeah that was like there's a who's
with a little kid next to him I'm lucky
lucky you didn't get [ __ ] stabbed bro
and he was one of the nice Philly fans
take that shirt off yeah he's a little
kid I go what the hell's going on oh
yeah there's a guy like you know that's
why they have a [ __ ] jail in a
[ __ ] courtroom inside they don't [ __ ]
around bro no dude everybody I mean I've
said before dude the Raiders
fans think that Vegas is gonna be a
pushover dude have you seen cops in
Vegas they're [ __ ] huge they crack
skulls do you know the ACH is part of
the budget they [ __ ] sure right they
all got white nipples that they [ __ ]
cut up and do a gag or real quick I did
it right off the nipple I mean it's the
only be met
I think Seattle and Vegas get the next
NBA team Seattle deserves one New
Orleans will probably move to Seattle
you know the Knights play in one of the
casinos out there they play at the you
know they playing at t-mobile Arena
which is like right next to see it's
like party's a triangle it's the dome
that's near I think it's not off topic
and it's all it's off the truck no it's
off Tropicana it's it's there Madeline
Bank called Excalibur is it there to
think beyond the helpers still there
dude
what Excalibur still no what I'm saying
is they had that old that they used to
do that Excalibur kicking it around
that's what they turned into a hockey
actually so no no let's play the
t-mobile which is gonna be used for aa
basketball that team will be there you
will see a team there I think it's gonna
be an NBA team yeah I think Memphis is
gonna move furniture ad for Memphis so
what's gonna happen with like LA wasn't
even a football market now you get the
Chargers and they get to LA Rams I mean
what the hey man I mean it's a huge
market I mean they I thought the Rams
were getting the team but I was not big
enough for two teams I mean you know
pick it up for - do you go to charge
games like oh it's like the stadium's at
the mwm be a game yeah they should
honestly it should have been Chargers
going to Vegas
the Raiders coming here but I mean
people freak out people think the
Raiders bring a certain element they
bring LA people nobody talks about all
the RAM fights that go on because it's
not part of the [ __ ] thing they the
NFL hates the Raiders because the al
davis who the [ __ ] out of them dude this
is gonna be a pretty stadium though is
this where the rams are gonna be playing
yeah yeah what is the best NFL say was
it Dallas's you think is it Atlanta over
Dallas
yeah yeah Allison I guess Lana - that's
right yeah I mean this is all like state
here the problem is like he's like you
know that you like soldier stadiums they
just like these have the technology now
it's like yeah I'm so happy the Dodgers
haven't got rid of Dodger Stadium tires
they could have mega diners are doing
improvements the knocking down of old
Yankee Stadium is the most offensive
thing I've ever seen you're tearing down
a museum yeah I like like you like
people like I'm gonna there's something
about like you know you know this like
when we tour I go do it like a theater
that's been around since the late 1800s
yeah so many [ __ ] soul cooties in
that [ __ ] place is so old cooties like
it's like [ __ ] playing somewhere
you're feel yeah you know do you look at
the water
Dean Martin Dean Jerry Lewis and all use
a Frank's and I played this same theater
you go this is [ __ ] awesome I like
that [ __ ]
I think people will appreciate like you
know the Yankee Stadium he toured the
dude you want to [ __ ] do this you
tear out the [ __ ] seats and you put
new seats a that's what Wrigley Field
did if you go to Wrigley Field it is
it's smells like baseball I agree with
you I like it's like some people want
they want the experience I don't go
travel the country going to the baseball
stadiums before they [ __ ] tear them
down before it becomes all this new age
corporate [ __ ] [ __ ] dude you
wanna I like that [ __ ] I mean you know
and stuff from a bygone era but I
[ __ ] love it oh look at the Comedy
Store it's a piece of [ __ ] and it's sold
out every night what go back in the
Bowery box but you get but I'm not I
don't get what you're seems like it you
just say oh what did you just [ __ ] on
Mecca
it is a Mecca
it's a Mecca unbelievable Chad this is
the worst episode
bridges always what you're on the
[ __ ] you're on a timeout dude you're
on a seven day time we're about to wrap
it up anyway we got a chat you know what
you telling me we wrap it up I'm going
another hour [ __ ] this place okay
[ __ ] them like you're going acapella
okay dude I hope you had a good time I
had a blast man I can't wait any
comments
[ __ ] all the time blah blah yeah well
listen a bit before you can chat it's
been a pleasure you were granted show
white last okay take care every time
check out my new album by everybody by
my new special joy here would not go by
my special [ __ ] is elbow okay okay
literally it's trying to give my out for
this album if you need a coaster let's
write to [ __ ] my album
[Laughter]